We've looked at Milton's earliest poem or what Milton wants us to think of as
his earliest poem from,
from,
from a couple of different perspectives.
So were you remember our examination on Monday of the naitivity owed,
which I took to be an early,
an early poetic achievement in Milton's career in which Milton himself took to
be an early poetic achievement in his career.
But we also looked at that the,
the naitivity owed is a poem or a kind of statement about the very nature of a,
of an early poetic achievement and about Milton's sense of the nature of a
poetic career in general.
Um,
and I think this,
this can be said,
uh,
this is true of a number of,
of,
of Milton's earliest lyrics.
The early poems are not merely a brilliant literary exercises in and of them in
and of themselves,
although of course they are.
They are,
that the early lyrics are also instances,
or what we can think of is moments in Milton's lifelong meditation on what it is
to be a poet.
And I think it's fair to say that Milton's reconceptualization of the role of
the poet really permanently altered the way in which later generations,
especially later generations of,
of writers and poets would imagine the work of poetry and imagine the power of
the poet.
And,
and I think in this respect,
Milton's contribution,
uh,
to the,
to,
to the western literary imagination is really unparalleled.
Milton represented himself as a poet more often and with more care and attention
than any English poet and he English poet before him.
And in fact,
it,
it often strikes us that Milton's poetry,
uh,
seemed so absolutely new and so original because he's really the first poet who
in a number of ways,
um,
in a number of different registers,
seems often to be doing little more than a describing himself,
justifying himself or accounting for himself.
And it's this procedure of self accounting that,
that I wanna focus on today as we look at Milton's amazing sense of his vocation
as a poet and Milton sense of poetry writing as an example of what,
what he calls in one context,
an example of credible employment.
Now,
Milton never writes a formal,
uh,
formal autobiography,
but the Milton's body of poetry and this enormous body of pros,
most of it polemical prose,
um,
this stuff is littered with what are clearly recognizably,
explicitly autobiographical passages.
And the degree do you find the degree to which you find yourself,
uh,
having some sort of affinity with this poet with Milton will probably correspond
to the degree to which you find yourself enjoying or having some kind of,
for Milton's propensity of,
of,
for self representation and self accounting.
One of the most,
I think one of the most striking experiences of reading Milton's prose works and
they're typically a political,
political tracts in,
in,
in nature,
um,
is the,
is the recognition of this writer's willingness to,
to insert himself to insinuate his own private private meditations,
his self reflections and into the otherwise public and often political concerns
of the,
of the treatise.
And so Milton will continually be saying in his prose tracts,
Oh,
uh,
I,
I just had an idea,
dear reader,
before I go on a perhaps,
perhaps I should say something about myself and I need to explain something to
you about where I'm,
where I'm coming from.
You wonder who I am to tell you this.
Let,
let me give you an account of myself and let me establish the reasons why you
need to go on listening to me and why you should believe my position on this or
that political or ecclesiastical topic.
It's this drive to constant self definition that becomes the characteristic
feature of,
of Milton's work for later generations.
Uh,
the,
the romantic poets like,
like Blake and Wordsworth and Shelley and Keats,
um,
in,
in the 19th century are continually looking back to just those moments in
Milton.
Milton's method of self justification and,
and surprising self assertion.
And because it was precisely in Milton's exercises,
an autobiographical writing that a crucial element of literary practice gets
established.
And that's the element of the poets meditation on the meaning of,
of his vocation as a poet.
Uh,
uh,
a mill Milton is,
is magnificently,
magnificently free of the pressures of,
of modesty and,
and reticence and that freedom.
The liberation from the though that burden,
um,
also becomes a,
an enormous part of,
of his appeal,
uh,
for later generations of writing writers.
Um,
this,
it's just a fact that Milton is shockingly unembarrassed about making public all
of his highest literary ambitions.
There's every indication that Milton believed at an,
as I mentioned before at an unconscionably early age that poetry was his
vocation.
And he's continually willing to make that,
uh,
that belief a public one.
And by vocation,
I'm not merely thinking of of a job,
although certainly the modern sense of vocation as a form of employment is
certainly one that's available to Milton and certainly president his in his
thinking about the vocation.
But I also mean vocation in its earlier a more etymologically pure sense,
the literal sense of the word vocation as a calling from the Latin vote,
Cari,
uh,
one's vocation is that to which one has been called,
called presumably by God to perform.
So you have to rather competing a senses of the word vocation here.
Vocation has employment and vocation as a calling and they're constantly for
Milton bleeding into one another.
These two sentence senses of the word and often struggling with one another.
We're competing with one another.
Milton was always wrestling with,
with the problem of vocation and all of its meanings and the problem of what a
calling actually is and how one actually knows one has a calling.
It is a problem that pulsates somewhere beneath,
uh,
most of the lines of poetry that Milton,
that Milton rights,
uh,
the,
the most stunning of all of the anticipatory career narratives that,
that,
that I had mentioned in the last class.
I'm appears in the passage of the reason of church government that,
that you,
uh,
that you read for today.
So I'm going to ask you to turn to your hues,
additions and look at the top of the top of the left hand column of page 668.
So page six 68.
This is where Milton describes the outpouring of enthusiasm that he received for
his poetry from a number of learning at Italians during his recent travels
travels to Italy.
So this is the top of the left hand column on six 68,
uh,
Milton.
I began thus far to assent both to them and diverse and diverse of my friends
here at home and not less to an inward prompting,
which now grew daily upon me.
And think about,
think about this inward prompting.
Is it the self's own prompting or is this a prompting?
A,
is this a prompting experienced internally,
it prompting of God,
of vocation and inward prompting,
which now go daily upon me.
That by labor and intense study,
which I take to be my portion in this life,
joined with a strong propensity of nature.
I agreed with all of these voices that I might perhaps leave something so
written to after times as they should not willingly let it die.
Now,
it's clear here that Milton is imagining this,
this future work,
the work that after times will not willingly let die as the fulfillment
fulfillment of a professional career.
We certainly don't hear,
have an image of a,
of a poet whose poetry is being written effortlessly or,
or easily as,
as the young Milton seems convinced.
Uh,
the,
the Shakespeare a Shakespeare's poetry had been written,
um,
in,
uh,
in the allegro and in Oh Pencil Rosso,
which you'll be reading soon.
Um,
or,
and especially on the leg row,
Milton is able to say that that Shakespeare simply warbled his wood notes wild.
He was able to produce all those magnificent place simply by instinct.
Um,
a kind of natural,
a natural urge produced,
a generated,
uh,
all of that poetry.
But Milton portrays himself as a laborer here,
a poet who by labor and intense study actually has to work,
uh,
to produce the great poem,
Milton's divine vocation.
His calling,
uh,
seems in this light to be something like a vocation in the modern sense.
It's a job,
that exact work or labor.
Now look at,
look at page six,
71.
Uh,
again on the top of the left hand column here,
Milton is elaborating on the details of his,
of his anticipation of his undying fame.
And it's extraordinary.
This is a,
this is a polemical tracked about a new way in which the church,
the Anglican Church government should be organized.
And what in the hell are are,
is,
is all of this doing here,
um,
Milton's reporting to the English people,
how he imagines,
um,
the,
his future literary fame.
It's a,
it's extraordinarily,
um,
and wonderfully inappropriate.
Milton Milton's not making just any idol suggestion that he will write a poem
that future generations will find themselves in capable of forgetting a,
this is the left hand column on six 71.
Neither do I think it's shame to covenant with any knowing reader that for some
few years yet I may go on trust with him toward the payment of that,
of what I am now indebted as being a work not to be raised from the heat of
youth or the vapors of wine like that which flows at waste from the pen of some
vulgar amorist or the trencher fury of a rhyming parasite out of nowhere.
You get this sense of anger on Milton's part in this kind of contempt that he
feels and he will feel for the rest of his life.
Of the,
his contempt of is a poetic competitors is contemporary,
uh,
his contemporary poets,
all of whom are vulgarians in this characterization,
uh,
nor to be obtained by the invocation of Dame memory and her siren daughters.
Uh,
these are all forms of poetic inspiration that Milton is declaring.
He is rejecting here.
Uh,
Milton's work.
The great work will emerge instead from devout prayer to that eternal spirit who
can enrich with all utterance and knowledge and sends out his Sarah Finn with
the hallowed fire of his altar to touch and purify the lips of whom he pleases.
This is a,
it's an amazing passage you have at the end of this sentence,
that same,
and you'll remember this,
that same image of prophetic preparation with which Milton had begun the
naitivity out,
that you remember that line from out his secret alter touched with hallowed
fire.
Like the old Hebrew Prophet Isaiah.
Milton will be inspired to,
to write his great work when the iniquity of his lips is purged.
W when they get Turnell spirit touches with hallowed fire,
the lips of whom he pleases.
And so Milton is going to be a great poet because it has pleased God to have
chosen him because God has called Milton deserve as a human conduit for,
for the conveyance of divine knowledge.
And so according to this concluding image here of this sentence,
Milton Nelson's imagining himself more or less than the traditional image of the
great biblical profits that the passive vehicle through which the deity
transmits his on inspiring message,
but the but,
but this pot pious subservience that you,
that you have a ending this passage.
Um,
and certainly it's consonant with that,
with that image from the naitivity owed.
Um,
nonetheless,
I think it's safe to say that it comes as quite a shock when you consider the
sentence as a whole.
Mount Milton had begun the sentence not with calm,
prophetic certainty about his divine vocation.
Um,
he began it with the far more secular set of images,
a set of images that comes from the world of business.
And it's a set of images that couldn't be more foreign,
are more alien to the prophetic mode of the,
of the Old Testament prophets.
Milton begins by saying that he was going to write a great work because he's
indebted because he owes the English pump,
the English people something after all of their patient waiting.
Uh,
nor nor do I think it's shame to covenant with any knowing reader that for some
few years,
yet I may go on trust with him toward the payment of what I am now indebted.
And according to this,
this image of the vocation of the poet Milton isn't claiming divine inspiration
at all.
Uh,
he,
he's,
he's making a deal.
I mean,
Walton makes a covenant with the reader.
It's as if he's signing a contract because he's asking for credit here.
Uh,
please let me borrow it.
You know,
what,
what on earth would his,
with the readers of this a polemical tracked care,
uh,
about Milton's literary future?
Um,
he's not,
he's,
he's no one to them except a prelim political polemicists.
But nonetheless,
this is Milton's,
uh,
a remarkable logic.
Please give me a little more time patient readers as,
as I,
as I prepare to write the great English epic and like any shrewd borrower,
Milton promises that the credit extended will prove an excellent investment.
Milton believe something so written to after times as they should not willingly
let it die.
So think about this sentence with it's combination of,
of commercial,
commercial rhetoric and prophetic language,
uh,
making explicit the competing models really for the production of the great of
the great poem.
So the first model is that the poem will be the result of the poets Labor,
his hard work,
the expensive,
which will be assumed by the readers credit.
Um,
that's the,
that's the secular,
the economic image.
And the second model is that the poem will be the consequence of,
of the poets humble,
humble prayers to the eternal spirit.
His spirit who doesn't,
who doesn't inspire the poet,
who works the hardest,
but simply the poet whom it pleases the spirit to inspire.
And so in the sentence that we've just looked at at some length,
now we've,
we have embodied in the,
in the form of a shifting argument I really slippery argument,
uh,
to the two senses of the word vocation,
vocation as a job and vocation as a divine calling.
And I go so far to say that most of the really truly memorable moments in
Milton's poetry and prose Ben generated by some version of just this conflict,
Milton's poetry is,
um,
is,
is always emerging from the gap between the competing meanings of a particularly
important and weighty concept like that,
a vocation.
Now,
some stuff to some extent we shouldn't find ourselves surprised that we,
uh,
that we see at the heart of Milton statement and anticipating his future
greatness.
A something of a contradiction,
a concerning the idea of a vocation.
It's just this uncertain status of the whole,
a whole raft of ideas associated with vocation that really fissured and
fractured the spiritual lives of countless 17th century puritans.
Milton is inheriting here,
uh,
and enormously rich tradition of thought on this subject.
Uh,
according to the 16th century Protestant theologian,
John Calvin Butts with Swiss theologian,
or actually French.
Uh,
but he lives in Geneva.
God chooses us.
God elects us for salvation and damnation.
We ourselves of course,
have no choice whatsoever in the matter.
And,
and,
and this,
this belief that's called Calvinist predestination is really at the heart of
mainstream English.
Puritanism at this point.
Um,
our salvation is entirely in God's hands,
but it seemed to a lot of followers of Calvin that it was a matter.
And you can imagine why it was a matter of some urgency in a matter of some
importance to know whether one had actually been elected by God for salvation.
We need some proof of our salvation and simply to get up in the morning.
Actually,
when you think about it,
and the only proof seem to lay for so many of Milton's contemporary seem delay,
uh,
in the degree of visible success that they seem to have enjoyed.
And so then,
uh,
much as now,
one of the most obvious signs of success was of course financial,
the meat material success.
The means by which we could discern whether Joe,
uh,
whether God had called on us to join the elect was by determining by discerning
the profitability of our vocation,
the vocation in the secular sense of the,
of employment.
And so you can probably see something like the strange,
the strangely perverse logic that could begin to attach itself to the puritan
belief in God's predestination of all human beings,
either to salvation or damnation.
Um,
I don't think this is it.
I,
I feel confident that this is not at all what uh,
Calvin had intended,
but it's what happened nonetheless to prove to others and maybe more important
to prove to oneself that one has already been predestined by God to,
uh,
for salvation.
One has to be successful.
And the only way to assure one success is to labor of course,
to work hard to achieve through effort that success,
which one,
uh,
secretly feared should already have been achieved by means of predestination.
Um,
obviously there's an irrational inversion of,
of cause and effect here.
And it's a magnificent paradox.
God chooses us based on no work of our own,
uh,
but we find ourselves working as pie,
as hard as we possibly can in order to demonstrate to ourselves that we have in
fact already been chosen
according to the,
according to the German,
the Mag,
the absolutely brilliant German sociologist,
Max Faber,
the founder of the discipline of sociology,
who,
uh,
who pioneers the,
the study of the sociological impact of,
of Protestant theology at the beginning of the 20th century.
Um,
it is precisely this backwards and cruel logic that's responsible for what he,
and it's a,
it's a,
it's an enormous claim,
um,
essentially,
uh,
insupportable but it's this backwards crazily inverted logic that's responsible
for the economic progress of the northern Europeans.
It's responsible for what,
uh,
vapor calls the emergence of the Protestant work ethic.
So historians and can and in fact have,
uh,
many times take an issue with a lot of Weber's historical claims,
but his,
uh,
he's invaluable,
I think for our purposes.
And then the understanding of Milton.
And for a lot of the cultural business of the 17th century in general,
the assumption among a lot of reformation,
Protestants and Milton's Day was that what God commands above all else is our
labor,
our investment,
and God expects after our labor and investment that we have something to show
for it.
At the end.
It's,
it's,
it makes sense that we have in some way profit.
And so it's,
it's here at this intensely awkward point at which Protestantism and capitalism
to seemingly utterly disparate spheres of activity and thought and being the
strange point at which these two things converge.
And it's at this intense intersection that we find,
we find John Milton,
do you understand the concerns of,
of Milton's poetry?
It,
it,
it is important and I'm convinced it's important to understand this,
this massive conjunction of economic and spiritual thought that's really at the
heart of the,
of,
of English Protestantism.
But that's just a part of the story.
There's also a more specific,
a more local reason for which our,
uh,
our John Milton was susceptible to the,
to this profit and loss rhetoric of,
of Calvinist puritan theology.
Milton Milton was the son of a banker or what?
Actually banks didn't exist at this point in the 17th century.
It's not until the Dutch invent banks,
uh,
late in the late,
in the 17th century.
Um,
but Milton was the son of what is the equivalent of a modern day banker.
He's what would have been called in the 17th century,
a scrivener or a goldsmith.
A Goldsmith was an early money lender and it was a perfectly respectable
profession as far as,
uh,
as Borzois a profession,
Sko and John Milton's senior,
uh,
has a,
has a pretty good living.
Um,
but it's in practice it's actually much more analogous I would think too,
what a modern day pawnbroker does.
So you would leave with John Milton Sr the goldsmith,
a portion of gold.
And on the basis of that collateral,
this is all a bit the business of collateral loans.
Pawnbroking you would,
on the basis of that collateral,
John Milton senior would lend you a sum of money for which you would pay him
interest and at the end of the loan,
upon your payment of the principal and have sufficient additional interest.
John Milton senior,
the Goldsmith,
um,
would return to you the goal that you had entrusted to him.
Now,
Mr Milton took some risks when he separated himself from his cash and lent money
to his clients,
let more money to his clients then the collateral,
the gold was actually worth and the motive for that risk of course,
that the motive for that investment was the expectation of a profit.
It's just this economic pattern of,
of risky investment and the expectation of a prophet that forms something like
that.
The Matic Paradigm,
uh,
the thematic paradigm of,
of profit and loss that really is at the heart of Milton's a representation of
his future literary greatness.
His,
his conception of himself as a poet,
Milton seems to have inherited from his father of language of commerce.
Uh,
a language that he was able to so easily and effortlessly to transpose,
transpose from his father's vocation as a goldsmith to his own anticipated
vocation.
As a poet,
Milton owes his father this whole lexical world of,
of,
of lending,
of borrowing and of profit.
But Milton owes his father more than that,
more than merely a set of metaphors,
images,
uh,
drawn from the world of his father's money lending.
And to understand exactly what it is,
the John Milton junior own stone,
Milton senior.
We have to look at the Latin poem that Milton writes to his father in 1637.
So let's look at that now.
Uh,
this is page 82 in the Hughes edition
and the poem is too my father odd pot trim.
And Milton expresses his debt of gratitude for his father's support.
Uh,
Milton graduated with,
with,
with an MBA from Cambridge University in July of 16,
1632.
He had studied hard obviously,
um,
and he had supposedly been preparing himself for his future career and that
would have been the career of a clergyman.
Milton's younger brother Christopher was,
was already,
uh,
entering law school at this time.
And it was clear,
it was clear,
I guess,
to everybody that Milton,
John,
Milton and junior was not suited to a profession in the law,
although I'm actually not sure why that's the case.
Court records show that,
uh,
our poet was exceedingly a litigious.
He brought suit against dozens and dozens of people throughout his entire life
attempting to redress a wide range of grievances through an appeal to the use of
the legal system.
But the vocation to which Milton seem to have been most suited was a life to
everyone around him was a life in the ministry.
His reading,
his learning,
his talents as an order.
All of these assets pointed to one potential career.
And in fact,
nearly everyone in the Mba class too,
in which Milton graduated turned to a career in the church.
This is what a master's degree could do for you.
Um,
in the early 17th century.
It was good for very little else.
Now we know,
or at least we have a retrospective inkling from our reading of poems like the
naitivity owed and other early poems that Milton on some level was imagining his
vocation to be that of a poet.
But then just as now,
uh,
one could obviously not be a poet by,
by profession.
You can't make a living writing poetry.
Uh,
no one's,
no one's ever made a living writing poetry who hasn't been patronized or given a
lot of money by someone who was much richer,
um,
than he or she is.
I'm maybe rob Macewan in the 60s,
made money writing poetry.
This neat main name would and should mean nothing to you.
But,
uh,
this,
this man sold a lot of,
uh,
millions of books have really bad poems.
Um,
with that exception,
I think very few people have actually,
um,
certainly in Milton's Day profited,
uh,
from the selling of their poems.
And Hilton's father would obviously a found unsuitable.
The idea that seven years of uni of expensive university education that he had
invested in his son would result in nothing more than a career in,
in what?
In poetry.
And so you can maybe some of you all too easily can imagine the arguments that
might've taken place within the,
within the Milton household.
Why don't you become a lawyer like your brother Christopher?
Why can't you get a job like,
like everybody else?
So you can just,
I'm going to ask you to imagine the domestic situation in the Milton household
and 1632,
uh,
Milton has just returned home after seven years at the university,
a university education so generously financed by his father,
who is actually now 70 years old.
And he was just turning a Milton and junior was just turning 24 and the 24 is
the canonical age at which young men were received for admission into the
priesthood.
It's like joining the army at 18 at 24.
That's what you do.
You,
if you have an MBA from Cambridge,
you enter the Anglican priesthood and a 24 year old Milton after seven years of
education simply decides not to go.
Instead of joining the ministry,
Milton instead returns home and he stays at home.
He stays at home without any means of supporting himself for six years.
So with the financial support of his father,
Milton stays at home and reads he,
he studies and it's in these years after his graduation from college that Milton
embarks on upon what is essentially a systematic study of all available
knowledge.
He commands a mastery of just about the entire Canon of western literary and
historical learning.
He prepares himself for what his father is still imagining will be the
priesthood.
Um,
uh,
but uh,
but,
but for what Milton is probably imagining will be his future career as a great
English poet and it,
and it's little wonder that one of the subjects of his meditations during this
period is the problem of vocation.
The,
the twin problem of what it is one is actually doing on the one hand and what it
is on the other hand that the father has called one to do it in Milton's poem to
his father and his earthly father.
And there becomes a confusion,
uh,
throughout Milton,
um,
with respect to which of Milton's fathers,
the heavenly or the earthly is calling him to do what [inaudible] and Milton's
poem to his father.
You have the poets attempt to justify himself before the man who seems to be
asking him to define his vocation.
So we have to assume that the occasion for this poem is the Co is some kind of
question posed by John Milton senior.
A question like,
to what end am I supporting you a son?
And if it's a poet that you want to be,
to what extent can the writing of poetry be considered respectable work?
Um,
Milton,
look at page.
This page is 82 and 83 in the Hughes.
Milton's expressing a dutiful degree of,
of filial piety,
gratitude.
And this will,
this,
this may seem familiar to I can never repay you.
He writes,
you have an account of my means and whatever.
And now we're on page 83 and whatever wealth I possess,
I have reckoned up on this paper for I have nothing except what golden Clio has
given.
And what has been the fruit of the dreams in a remote cavern and of the Laurel
groves of the sacred would end of the shadows of Parnassus.
I have nothing to show for,
for,
for all of your investment,
but my learning,
all of that,
which Golden Cleo has promised me,
Cleo,
the Muse of history.
I have also my aspiration,
my aspirations,
my dreams of becoming a great poet because I dwell among these highly literary
that the sacred wood in the shady groves on Parnassus.
Now,
Milton explains that he has nothing now of course,
to show for his father's investment.
Uh,
but he will look at the,
look at the last stanza.
This is a,
at the top of page 86 in the Hughes and Milton turns to address his own poetry.
This is how he concludes that this poem,
I'd pop trim and you my juvenile versus,
and amusements,
if you only dare hope for emerge immortality and a life and a glimpse of the
light beyond,
uh,
beyond your master's funeral pyre.
And if Darko Bolivian does not sweep you down to the throngs of Haiti's,
perhaps you will preserve this eulogy.
And the name of the father who my song honors as an example to remote ages at
Melton's,
essentially making a covenant.
This is a contract with his father.
But in this passage,
he's engaging his father into a contractual situation just as he will,
um,
engage the entire English people as we've already seen in the reason of church
government,
if his father continues to support him.
This is the magnificent logic here.
If the father continues to support him,
he will repay his father with his own future fame,
a name that his fellow Englishman will not willingly let die.
Now,
Milton's fame will preserve his father's name and of course it has a throughout
the agents,
uh,
needless to say,
the satisfaction of John Milton Sr and we'll have to be postponed to the great
hereafter.
He will not be able to reap the profit of his investment in his son study until
not only after his own death,
but of course after his son's death as well.
That's Milton's Milton's logic here.
But then who would understand,
who would understand better than John Milton's Sr the importance or the value of
a longterm investment strategy?
There's a,
there's a tone of,
of,
of self assuredness and have confidence and certainty in this poem that I have
to say isn't always matched.
And the other works that writing in this same period in most of the other
writings that you've looked at for today,
though,
the weird Calvinists logic surrounding the,
the idea of divine predestination makes it impossible for Milton to be that
comfortable or are that confident about the idea of a,
of a true poetic vocation.
How can melt and know that he was really and truly called by God to be a great
poet until he writes something.
It's not,
it's not a bad question.
And until he has something actually to show for his talent.
And how can Milton have anything to show for his talent until he's,
this is the logic.
Until he has patiently waited for God to inspire him to write.
He can't know until he's been inspired to write.
And he can of course start writing until he's been inspired.
And it's a,
it's a,
it's a peculiar but familiar double bind.
Um,
it,
it's a puzzle that pre approved infinitely anxiety producing for the young
Milton and it's,
it's really their productive engine that keeps this extremely anxious poet going
in the early years.
It's,
it's just this double bind,
a vocation that that's the subject of the sonnets.
Seven,
how soon?
Half the time.
That's the soldered in which Milton laments the fact that he has turned 23 years
old and has yet produced nothing that would indicate a shining poetic future.
And so,
and in that poem,
and as in the other things that you read for today,
Milton is attempting to,
to understand the problem of vocation through this specific lens of,
of scripture.
Uh,
and that's what we're going to look at now.
Nearly every conceptual problem,
uh,
available,
that was puzzled over in the 17th century could be processed and understood in
some way.
In terms of a related problem in the Bible.
Um,
every conflict and contradiction within an individual or within the society at
large could be interpreted by means of a related conflict or related
contradiction.
Cold somewhere,
uh,
from the writings of scripture.
And,
and if you're puritans like Milton,
there were some especially important moments in scripture that could be used to
tackle the problem of vocation.
Uh,
there were particular moments in the Bible that seem best suited to answer this
question.
The question,
what did,
what is it that I'm supposed to do and what does it mean actually to do
anything?
But what does it mean to do anything in a world in which God seems to be so
entirely in control of all of our doings and of our actions?
Uh,
those passages of the Bible that seemed to have been particularly useful for
this dilemma where two parables,
uh,
from the New Testament and that those were,
those are represented in the packet,
the parable of the talents and the parable of the workers in the vineyard.
And,
and you will soon be seeing innumerable ways in which these parables continue to
creep up,
uh,
in,
in Milton's verse the language.
And we can also think of the of it as the ideology of these parables are
constantly surfacing in Milton and they provide something like a divinely
authorized focal point for what I had mentioned earlier,
this strange intersection of spirituality and economics.
And I had,
I know it's a little difficult to read,
but I included nonetheless than the packet.
Uh,
the Geneva Bible,
that's the great 16th century Puritan Bible,
that version of these,
these two parables,
a written before the King James because it provides all of those glosses,
those marginal annotations on the side,
those incredibly mean spirited and dark Calvinist interpretations of,
of,
of the Bible.
I'm convinced that those glosses those annotations.
Uh,
uh,
rove,
Milton absolutely mad and so much of his own rewriting of the Bible essentially
in,
in paradise lost is a response to a lot of the annotations of the Bible that he
grew up reading.
So the first parable that when you have to look at is the one that instilled
without question the one that instilled the most anxiety in Milton.
And that's the parable of the talents for Matthew 25.
So this is the parable of the talents.
A master distributes his wealth to his servants,
um,
and the,
and the wealth wealth is distributed in the,
in the form of a coin.
And the name of the coin is translated in English with the word talent.
And it's precisely the word here.
Uh,
for this coin that gives us our modern word,
our modern word,
talent,
which means a skill of course,
or a predisposition.
Now,
think about that,
that our word talent has its origin in this parable should give you a sense of
the,
the extraordinary cultural weight that this parable,
um,
has assumed.
Okay.
Um,
to one servant,
the master gave five talents.
You remember this story to one servant.
The master gave five talents to another.
He gave two into a third servant.
He gave one talent.
When the master returns from his journey,
he learns that the first two servants had wisely and piously invested their
talents and they had doubled their money.
They had profited and the master praises them.
Uh,
but the servant who had been given only one talent hidden the talent in the
earth.
So as perfectly understandably so as not to risk the only talent,
the hit that he'd been given.
And I think the genius of this parable hinges on the fact that the servant who
was only given one talent seems to be re,
uh,
acting so perfectly reasonable,
reasonably with,
uh,
with a lot of,
a form of caution and hesitation you could actually say.
And so he explains to the master,
I knew that Western hard man,
which repurposed where thou,
so it's not an gathering where thou straws not.
I was therefore afraid.
And I went,
I went and hid by talent in the earth
because the servant had not been willing to spend the only talent that he had
been given.
The master instructs him to give his one and only talent to the man who now has
10.
And the master concludes with an imperative that is surely one of the most
terrifying utterances in the entire Bible cast there for cast.
Therefore,
that unprofitable servant into utter darkness,
there shall be weeping and gnashing of teeth.
Don't know.
Conclusion of this parable seems so,
so violent.
Uh,
perhaps because the lesson to be learned from the parable is,
is,
is so uncertain.
Uh,
Milton seems to have been drawn to the parable as a way of,
of understanding the expectations placed upon him by his master.
Actually his two masters or his two fathers.
There's first the,
the earthly father John Milton's senior who had given Milton the talent of an
expensive education and then six years of additional,
uh,
heavily subsidized study.
And there's also the heavenly father who had given Melton is rhetorical gifts
and expected him to use them in some way,
uh,
for God's benefit presumably to use them in some way beneficial to the church.
The most obvious way being naturally the vocation of the ministry and the
parable is a,
is a horrifying one because it places such an unspeakable pressure on the
interpreter to produce something,
to show something for himself at the end of the day.
And for Milton whose temperament up to at this point in client him obviously the
hesitation to postponement and to merely the anticipation of profit.
The pressure applied by this parable of the unprofitable servant,
uh,
may very well have seen utterly unbearable,
but there was another,
there was another parable,
another of Jesus's parables that also treated the problem of vocation and like
the parable of the talents.
Um,
it provided what seemed to be a model for,
of kind of pattern of action,
um,
and or actually the trajectory of a career.
And this is the parable of the workers in the vineyard.
And here a householder looks for laborers that he will pay a penny a day.
The laborers who began it to work at dawn earn a penny.
The Labor is hired in the third hour,
earn a penny,
and the laborers who stood idle in the marketplace until the 11th hour,
we're asked who are asked to do nothing until the last possible moment.
Um,
they also received a penny for their pains.
At the end of the day,
they're paying such as they were.
Now,
when asked by the hardest workers,
why each of the laborers received every man a penny,
the householder replies take that which is nine own and go.
They way I will give unto this last as much as to the so in this parable,
which suggests something like,
which is suggested to,
uh,
generations of readers.
Uh,
something like a socialism reform of communism.
The amount of labor actually expended is immaterial.
The late comer to the job is rewarded the same as the worker who was there from
the very beginning and working from the very beginning and as a model for
economic activity or as a kind of vocation guide.
This parable couldn't be more opposed or to some wouldn't seem more opposed to
the parable of the unprofitable servant.
The men who stood around and did nothing until they were called to act or in
precisely the same amount as those who have been laboring in the vineyard all
day.
They're not punished for their unprofitable expectation or they're not punished
for just waiting around to be called the work.
They're not bidding to be cast out into utter darkness where there's weeping and
gnashing of teeth there.
They're rewarded for their waiting.
This parable may seem,
I think to be a little more compatible with Milton's general temperament in the
years of his,
of his studious retirement as a young man consumed with anxiety about,
about his failure yet to do anything,
whether to gain,
whether to gain employment as a clergyman or to produce somehow some great work
of literature.
Milton's continually seeking assurance that the late comer,
and this is how he's thinking of himself,
that the latecomer will be rewarded,
that the latecomer,
we'll be actually able to produce something when he is called to produce
something for Milton.
These,
these two parables,
I'm locked in a powerful,
a powerful dialectical relation to one another.
The parable of the talents,
uh,
rewards,
hard work and investment and it,
and it's satisfying because it does that,
but it also instills an anxiety of non productivity.
Uh,
the parable of the vineyard assures us that,
that God rewards us regardless,
regardless of our herd,
hard work and investment,
but only for cold only if God chooses us,
um,
chooses to call us.
And so the,
you can see the strange dialectic developing here.
The anxiety aroused by one parable necessitates almost the constellation that's
offered by the other one.
Uh,
but the consoling parable sooner rouse its own anxieties,
uh,
which can only be,
which only can be quieted by recourse to the other parable.
Uh,
and the result,
needless to say,
as is his mind spinning.
Uh,
and we're,
we're all familiar with at least a version of this.
We,
all of us just as human beings,
we,
all of us want to be rewarded.
We want to be loved for our hard work,
and we're all working really hard here.
But of course,
we also want to be loved.
We want to be rewarded unconditionally without any contingencies whatsoever.
That,
that on some level,
that's just the human condition.
And Milton uses these to the language of these two parables to get at this,
this,
this problem that has resonances in every conceivable sphere.
Now,
shortly after Milton composed the Sonnet,
um,
how soon halftime,
the Sonnet number 25,
um,
he wrote a letter to a friend in which he enclosed this poem.
The,
the,
the sonnet.
Now we don't know this is in the packet.
Um,
after the parables,
we don't know the intended recipient of this letter and we actually have no,
no idea whether Milton actually sent the letter.
But a couple of drafts of this letter actually exist in Milton's own hand.
And the letter is clearly a document that Milton had devoted some energy and
some time to,
and we need to look at it.
The unnamed friend sounds quite a bit actually like Milton's disapproving
father.
The friend is obviously chided Milton for not doing anything with his life.
Milton has shown so much promise.
He possessed so many obvious talents that can be poured into the profession for
which he was so clearly suited the profession of the ministry.
But Milton was remaining at his father's house and what seemed like a perpetual
state of humiliating self infantilization.
Um,
he seems to have been nothing doing nothing but reading,
acquiring more knowledge,
and really essentially just learning for the sake of learning.
And so Milton responds to what he takes to be this objection.
He responds in the second paragraph of the letter in the left hand column of the
packet,
um,
to the,
to this criticism that he's done.
So Little Milton acknowledges that the course he's chosen for himself may not be
a natural one.
Nature herself pushes a young man to begin a family and to seek credible
employment.
Milton rights,
the natural desire for fame seated and then in the breast of every true scholar
usually pushes him to make haste by the radius way of publishing and divulging
conceived merits.
But it's just this making haste toward publication writing something really
great right now that,
that Milton's resisting here,
he claims to be studying and learning rather than producing right now.
And there's,
and there's a problem with just studying and learning and it's a problem at
Milton can't avoid it.
It's possible that in merely reading and in merely amassing more and more
knowledge,
Milton's doing little more the than the unprofitable servant in Matthew 25.
It's possible that he's hiding his talent or burying his conceived merits deep
within the earth.
And it's this frightening possibility that Milton forces,
uh,
that that Melton forces himself to engage head on the implications of this,
of this parable.
Look at the,
uh,
in the packet near the,
this letter near the top of the right hand side of the page.
Milton claims that his love of learning might seem to contradict the parable of
the talents the master had commanded his servants of course,
to do something to show a profit in a due and timely fashion.
But Milton wants his friend here to know that there's of course nothing to worry
about.
This is how Milton's mind is,
is,
is working overtime here.
This is,
and this is the argument,
Milton's pursuing his learning.
He's postponing his publication because it's his job really to consider the
masters.
Great commandment all the more closely that the point of the parable,
Milton explains this is an unbelievable misreading of the,
of the biblical text.
The point of the parable is not that the servant should have invested is one
talent just anywhere the servants problem was that he didn't take enough time.
He didn't carefully consider the command because it careful consideration of the
masters command,
and I'm quoting here,
does not press forward as soon as maybe to undergo,
but keeps off with the sacred reverence and religious advisement.
How best to undergo not taking thought of being late so as to give advantage to
be more fit.
Unbelievable.
You look at a passage like that and complete astonishment.
Milton has invoked of course,
to his own detriment.
What was he thinking?
That the parable of the unprofitable servant,
the parable of the talents,
but he invokes it to show that if one really reads it carefully enough,
one can see that the lesson to be drawn has nothing whatsoever to do with the
due and timely investment of one's talent.
What this parable really teaches us is that we do best to wait.
We do best to consider the command to consider all of the possible investment
strategies.
Maybe we want to go into the ministry.
Maybe we want to go into poetry.
Perhaps we want to write like Shakespeare.
Maybe we want to be a writer like the great.
Um,
I'm an Old Testament Prophet Isiah,
but the last thing we should be burdened with Milton suggesting here is the fear
of being late.
Now,
I don't have to tell you that Milton has done a powerful violence to this
parable in Matthew.
No,
now God only knows what this parable actually means.
I mean,
it's truly,
it's perfectly inscrutable as far as I'm concerned.
But I think I can say with absolute certainty,
certainty that one of its possible significances cannot be that the unprofitable
servant should have waited to make his investment.
And now I think of it,
if Milton had been the servant,
he wouldn't even have made it to the stage of bearing the stupid coin in the
earth.
You would be consumed with the consideration of whether to bury it here or
whether it or bury it there,
or should he buried two feet under?
Or maybe he should vary at six feet under.
Now we haven't.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
I'm going to a,
okay,
I'm going to stop there.
Um,
there's a lot more to say about the parable of the talents and the parable of
the laborers or laborers in the vineyard.
Um,
but we have a,
we have run out of time.